The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we have Arvind
today going to talk about how
actually do parallelism much
closer to hardware and all the
work we have been doing.
ARVIND: So first, just
a clarification.
This talk is not really
about any techniques.
This is some very primary ideas
that I have some new
ideas on parallel programming.
The second thing is 5, 6 years
ago I was going around the
country giving a talk, why
hardware design can't be left
to hardware designers.
Because I think the way they
expressed their ideas is very,
very low level from software
point of view.
So I have worked pretty hard
on injecting some fairly
sophisticated ideas from
software into hardware design.
But it often happens when you
deal with powerful people, you
get effected by it.
So I have sort of come
the full cirlce.
Now I'm going to show you how
hardware design can influence
software design and
that's really the
idea behind this talk.
So that's borrowing some ideas
from hardware design.
Cell processor is a very good
example of a system on a chip
and this is what everybody
believes the
future will look like.
That you'll have fairly
symmetric things in some sense
and that is needed by hardware
because hardware gets out of
hand if you have wires running
all over the place.
So people would like these
things to be fairly regular in
some sense, but that doesn't
mean that all these styles
have to be the same.
So for example, you may have
very application specific
blocks on your chip.
So for example, in your cell
phone you have many, many
blocks which are specialized,
especially all the radio
communication.
Because if you did that stuff
in software you may not be
able to meet the performance and
even if you can meet the
performance your battery will
drain instantaneously.
I mean, it just takes too much
power to do that kind of
computation in software.
So for various reasons we need
application specific
processing units and I'm
sure cell processor has
quite a few of these.
By the way, these application
specific units, they're often
called ASICs.
And you can think of them as
a separate chip, but in due
course of time they become
blocks of a bigger thing.
You may have general
purpose processors.
Already, systems have more
than one such thing.
Cell processor has how many?
Like 8.
PROFESSOR: Depends.
Some have 8, but they
don't [OBSCURED]
So the current Playstations
already list supposedly 7, but
we've had only 6.
So, the [OBSCURED].
PROFESSOR: And high-end cell
phones have 2 general purpose
processors and 2 DSPs on it,
so you certainly have --
multiple processors you will
have memory banks, et cetera.
And you will have structured
on-chip
interconnection networks.
ARVIND: So I think this
is not controllers.
That this is what the trajectory
will look like in
the future.
That doesn't mean that all the
chips will look the same.
You may have different mixes of
things depending upon the
application and one of the
interesting things is can you
put together one of these things
fast enough because
it's very, very expensive
to design and
implement these things.
So really one issue that comes
up all the time is can we
rapidly produce high quality
chips and surrounding systems
and software for such thing?
So this talk, as I said, it's
about ideas and what I'm going
to do is I'm first going to tell
you how I used to think
about parallel programming.
And this way is all
about threads.
You know, where are
my threads?
And I worked on this problem
for a very, very long time.
Like 20 years and this is not
necessarily wrong, You know
I'm sure in this course itself
you have seen quite a bit
about this and I think
tomorrow's lecture is on Cilk
so you will see even
more about threads.
And lately, I've been thinking
about it differently.
And really the main point I
would like to get across
somehow to you is now I think of
parallel little programming
module as a resource.
What do you mean
as a resource?
I'll try to make it more
concrete, this idea.
And the whole issue here is
I think this viewpoint is
valuable, but it's
not proven yet.
You know, so it may
not be right.
So just a warning.
I've been working with this on
students, in particular.
Now those of you who have
heard of transactional
programming, lots of things I
will say you'll say oh, you
mean a transaction?
Yes, I mean there are very, very
strong connections for
transactional stuff, but that's
not the language I'm
going to be using here.
These slides are color-coded.
So when I was talking about old
world thinking it's yellow
and when it's new thinking
then it's white.
So well, I think you probably
have already heard this.
That the only reason for
parallel programming used to
be performance.
This made programming
extremely difficult.
You had to know a lot
about the machine.
You were programming in code
were not portable.
Endless performance tuning,
all this still goes on.
I mean, very few of these
things have changed.
Parallel libraries were
not composable.
And this is one of the main
things I worry about a lot and
I think Allen was alluding
to it too.
Somebody has code, he just wants
to run the damn thing.
You know, even at factor
of 2 speed that
would be what fantastic.
You know, often it
runs slower.
Very, very fun, machines.
Very different to deal with
heap structures and memory
hierarchies.
And then there is always the
synchronization cost issue.
In some sense parallel
programming doesn't make sense
if there is no synchronization
going on and that's like this
embarrsingly parallel
computation you just start off
and things never talk
to each other.
In even moderately interesting
parallel programs there's
always some communication
between various tasks and when
that happens synchronization
cost becomes an issue and it
is such a major issue right
now that you have to think
about it out front.
Oh, if I synchronize too much
then I know for a fact that my
program's going to
run like a dog.
So you try to avoid
synchronization and make
things coarser and so on.
Really the whole issue used to
be how to exploit hundreds of
threads from software because
new hardware will support
many, many threads.
But at the same time, it's
important to understand that
in this world there's always
virtualization.
So number of threads in your
machine is never going to
match exactly what you have
in your application.
So any programming model you
have, virtualization is a very
important aspect of it.
That I have n threads and n may
be dynamic, maybe varying
with time in my application,
but in hardware I have some
fixed number of threads.
Which is significantly smaller
in general than what you have
in your application.
So the thing I was most
interested in all those days
was what I call implicit
parallelism.
And from the questions I was
hearing about analysis you're
doing of your programs, all
those issues come up there.
You know, given some code can I
figure out what can be done
in parallel and just
run it like that?
So expect parallelism from
programs written in sequential
languages and people like some
of the champions in this and I
have also spent lots
and lots of time on
this research problem.
So this is one of those areas
which certainly has not
suffered because of
lack of research.
There's tons and tons
of research in this.
You know, you can go to IBM and
there will be 50 Ph.D.'s
working on Fortran compiler.
Trying to extract parallelism.
But the success is limited.
In fact, the main takeaway from
this research is people
have learned now how they should
write their programs so
that compiler has a chance of
extracting parallelism.
Because now people look at your
code, they say, well,
this is a bad code.
Why?
Because compiler can't
analyze it.
You become part of the
equation in this.
Now the methodology I was
pushing for a long time was
functional languages.
Programs in functional languages
which may not
obscure parallelism in
the first place.
I'm not going to talk about
functional languages.
It's immaterial, you know,
whether this is a good idea or
a bad idea, the fact of matter
is in real life people's
reaction is functional
languages--
are you kidding me?
So it doesn't get off ground.
It's one of those things I can
come and preach to you is good
for your soul.
And they leave me alone.
I don't do movies
with subtitles.
AUDIENCE: Sorry to temporarily
derail you--
ARVIND: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Sorry to temporarily
derail you, so what kind of
parallelism is easier
to extract from
a functional language?
I can clearly see some task
parallelism, can you also
extract data parallelism
or pipeline
parallelism or what not?
ARVIND: It turns out that's
actually not that right
question to ask in the
functional language because
functional language doesn't
obscure the parallelism that
was there in the first place.
So you already have a partial
order on operations as opposed
to a sequential order.
You see when you write in
Fortran even a simple thing
like f of g of x, h of y.
It may be obvious to a
functional programmer that
these things can be
done in parallel.
Perhaps, the execution of these
can overlap with the
evaluation of f, but that's not
the semantics of Fortran
or any other sequential
language.
The semantics is you're supposed
to execute the
program left to right,
top to bottom.
So you will go and execute g
first and you'll go inside g
and execute it and then you will
go and execute h and then
you will go and execute f.
Why is that important?
Because there are side effects,
so it's conceivable
that you do something in this
which affects this and so on.
So you're given a sequential
order and then compiler does
deep analysis, the kind you're
doing right now it terms of
dependence and anti-dependence
and so on.
Which says it's OK to do
g and h in parallel.
Well, if it was a functional
program then you know by the
semantics of the language g and
h can be done in parallel.
That doesn't mean it's a good
idea to do it in parallel.
So when we get to the second
point of mapping this
computation onto a given
substrate off 2 processors or
10 processors then problems
become similar.
But the problem of detecting
parallelism is very different.
Because you don't talk of
detecting parallelism in
functional languages,
it's already there.
You don't obscure it.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, maybe.
ARVIND: And it goes without
saying that if your algorithm
has low parallelism then
functional languages or any
other language and there's
no magic--
you can't suck blood
out of stone.
You have to know
your algorithm.
what operations
can be done in parallel.
So language only is an aid.
In some sense that if it was
parallel I could express it
more easily as a parallel
program.
And if it's a bad language, you
obscure it and then you
try to undo the damage.
Now as I said, there has been
a lot of success in this in
terms of dense matrix kind of
stuff, but more irregular the
computation harder it gets to
do these things statically.
So when you can't do it then
people of course, designed
explicitly parallel programming
models and some of
the most successful ones in
this are data parallel and
you'll hear about
multithreading tomorrow in Cilk.
And then there are very low
level models where you are
doing actual message passing
between various modules that
are sitting over there and I
can expose you threads and
synchronizations that are
very low-level fork
and joint, et cetera.
So of course, high-level models
are preferable because
you're likely to make fewer
errors in them.
The question is, can
we compile them?
And in some cases what turns out
is this is a good model,
but it is not general enough.
So if you have a data parallel
algorithm, fine.
I mean, you should
use these things.
But not all applications fit
the data parallel model,
multithreading in some sense
is more general.
This is what I mean by a
multithreaded model that you
may have a main which
spawn off things.
So not only these things can
be done in parallel, but
execution of these can overlap
the execution of f.
So parents and children may be
executing simultaneously.
So if you look at this as an
activation tree, this invokes
a loop which has many, many
iterations in it.
When we talk of sequential
computing you're always
sitting on one branch of this.
So that's the stack.
This stack, this stack,
stack frames.
When you talk of parallel
computing then part of this
activation tree is concurrently
active.
So all problems get harder.
Storage management
gets harder.
And what gets especially harder
is that there is this
global heap.
You always have heap in
interesting programs, global
data structures.
Now the problem is if this and
this are active at the same
time or this and this are active
at the same time and
they are both reading and
writing into the data
structure then naturally
there's a race
condition in this.
Even if only 1 guy's writing and
5 people are reading it.
It's a question of the guy
should not read it too soon.
So the moment you do any kind
of parallel programming,
synchronization issues
arise immediately.
You know, you always have to
worry about, how do I indicate
that it's OK to read this?
Well, you can follow
some control ideas.
You say, this guy was writing.
He has finished execution, so
it must be OK to write.
Or you can go to very
fine-grained synchronization,
you can have some bit here which
says, oh this data has
been updated, now it's
OK to unlock it and
read it and so on.
So all these ideas have been
explored and they're still
being explored in
this context.
The main takeaway is instead
of a stack you will have a
tree which is active
at the same time.
Many, many things
are going on.
And the second thing is that
there is a competition.
There is a race in reading the
heap data structures and
therefore you have to worry
about that you don't read it
too soon or you don't write it
too soon because if you write
it too soon you may clobber
before somebody else gets a
chance to read it.
So these issues are
quite serious.
Now it's really possible--
I mean, I claim you know, I
have languages which can
express computation very
efficiently this way.
Efficiently is not
the right word.
Very easily you can express
computation in this way.
But at the end of the day the
goal is to take that stuff and
run it somewhere on some
parallel machine.
Whether it was cell processor in
the old days if would have
been parallel machines
of various ergs.
And that has proven to be quite
difficult, efficient
mapping of these things because
it turns out that you
say, oh, you didn't tell me
before you have only 2
processors.
Then I would have expressed the
computation differently.
Or you didn't tell me that
you have 1000 processors.
So there is this kind of yes,
there is virtualization.
But it's not virtualization
enough.
Qualitatively matters a lot.
You know, what is the target?
And that effects how you would
have expressed the
computation.
So I used to go around saying
this all the time that
parallel programming
is so important.
That really sequential
programming will be taught as
a special case of parallel
programming because it will be
all parallel.
If you have only one processor
then we can teach you some
special tricks how to run it
efficiently on one processor.
So this as you can see, is
largely an unrealized dream.
AUDIENCE: That's an old idea,
but not one to be dismissed.
ARVIND: Not one to
be dismissed.
Absolutely.
So the question is, has
the situation changed?
And the situation has
certainly changed.
So multicores have arrived.
This is a big deal.
I mean, Microsoft wants to
exploit parallelism.
There can be no bigger
indication than this.
And there is explosion
of cell phones.
And if you don't understand what
that means economically,
you know there are 100 million
PCs that will be sold this
year and 950 million
cell phones that'll
be sold this year.
This is the same kind of
transition that is taking
place that happened in the early
80s when we went from
mainframes and mini- computers
to micros.
So what happens there determines
what happens
everywhere else.
So it's quite possible then what
happens on these small
devices, hand-held devices
will determine the
architecture of everything
else just
because of the numbers.
People are willing to invest
a lot more money into this
explosion of game boxes.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
ARVIND: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: The explosion of
laptops is also happening.
ARVIND: Yeah, but still that
number is 100 million.
While cell phone is 950 million,
at least in 2000.
AUDIENCE: These are
cell processors.
ARVIND: Right.
Absolutely.
So look, if I'm talking to you
as a teacher I mean, my
message to my colleagues in
the department is it's no
longer good enough to say well
we'll teach you parallelism
when you're a sophomore.
I mean, it is the thing that
people want to deal with.
You say, what do you
mean telling me how
to program one processor.
I have 10 of them
in my pocket.
So I think we have to
deal with this.
You know, how do we introduce
parallelism?
What method we should have for
teaching parallel programming
so that is the default
programming
model in your head?
So it's all about
parallelism now.
No longer an advanced topic.
It has to be the first topic.
Just another word of
caution in this.
So let's look at cell phones.
So mine has some bugs in it so
sometimes it misses a call
when I'm surfing the web.
It doesn't rate.
So this is the deep question
now, so whose fault is it?
So for example, to what extent
the phone call software should
be aware of web surfing software
or vice versa.
So now you have to understand
how these things are done.
Of course, how the phone calls
are made, that software has
been evolving, right?
You can look at it all in the
last 15 years and you'll be
able to trace a continuum.
You know how phone calls are
made and that's not trivial
among the software on
your cell phone.
Well, when it comes to web
surfing software I can
guarantee you it was not
written from scratch.
People went to your PC,
they say, what do
you do on your web?
They take all that software
say, let's port
it on the cell phone.
Now the guy who wrote the web
software never thought that
you would be talking on
telephone while you're surfing
the web or at least not
on the same device.
And vice versa, the guy who
wrote the phone software never
thought you would be surfing the
web while you're talking
on the phone.
I mean even 1995 or 1998 if
somebody had said, you'll be
surfing the web at
the same time.
It would have sounded
pretty bizarre.
Is it merely a scheduling
issue?
So this is the answer saying
ah, they didn't process the
interrupt properly.
I'm sorry, this is not just
a scheduling issue.
I don't even know the
semantics of this.
So for example, if you're
surfing the web and the phone
rings do you really want to stop
surfing the web and pick
up the phone?
I mean, what's so special
about phone?
There is nothing being indicated
from the language
point of view.
It may be application
requirement that you want to
stop it or not stop
it and so on.
Is it a performance issue?
That oh, it's because you have
only 2 processors in this.
If you had 4 this problem
will go away.
Or if you could just run it
faster it will go away.
I don't think any of these
answers are right.
I mean, the bottom line in this
is sequential modules are
often used in concurrent
environments with unforeseen
consequences.
So your mindset has to be that
I'm going to put together a
parallel program with lots
of existing things.
Because you can't keep giving
the answer oh, let's just
rewrite it again from scratch.
Because amount of software
is so enormous in this.
What we should worry about
now is how we should
design these modules.
How we should write pieces of
software or design hardware so
that we can put together an
ensemble of them, a collection
of such modules so that they
do something useful.
And it's all about
parallelism.
And how to do all this in
a parallel setting.
OK, so new goals as opposed
to old goals.
So I don't want to think in
terms of decomposition.
I don't want to think in terms
of here is my clever
algorithm, how do I decompose it
so that this runs here and
this runs here and so on.
Instead I want to think
in terms of synthesis.
That you've already given me
lots of modules, which are
very useful.
Which perhaps are written
by domain experts.
They know something
about that stuff.
And can I put together a
bigger application very
quickly from it?
And you know, another favorite
example of mine in this regard
is FFTW and linear
algebra packages.
Both have been optimized
to the hilt, right?
And if somebody gives you an
application which calls FFT
and uses enough linear algebra
I guarantee you that program
will not be easy to write in
spite of the existence of both
these packages, which are
extremely well optimized.
So there is something we're not
paying attention to is,
how do we bring parallel modules
together in such a way
so that the functionality, the
performance, et cetera are
unpredictable in some sense?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
What's your point?
I think I agree with your point,
I just want to make
sure I understand your point.
That FFTW linear algorithm
is not enough and
so there will be--
ARVIND: No, no.
I think it's very
well done, FFTW.
Linear algebra is
very well done.
But we still haven't provided
any good way of thinking in
terms of two parallel things.
You know, what happens
when they interact?
So if my program is calling
FFTW often and then it's
calling linear algebra often.
AUDIENCE: You weren't here when
I mentioned that but I
was actually bringing up the
point of linear algebra and
FFTW working together.
Just working.
ARVIND: Exactly.
Absolutely.
I'm saying in that sense, you
see, this is a difference way
of thinking because the old way
of thinking well, give me
your application.
Now let's decompose it.
The point is I don't have
experts who can write FFTW as
well as Matel wrote it.
Or who's linear algebra packages
are being written.
I want to use those things.
I want to synthesize large
parallel programs quickly.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How does the Apple
iPhone work with--
ARVIND: I'm sorry, how does?
AUDIENCE: The iPhone.
AUDIENCE: Apple iPhone.
ARVIND: Apple iPhone?
AUDIENCE: Yes, they have the
operating system on there--
ARVIND: I think from our point
of view that's the same thing.
Is just that the user interface
is guaranteed to be
far superior because in my phone
when I see the icons I'm
a techie and I still can't
understand half of them.
So I like Apples idea.
You know, phone, pictures.
[OBSCURED]
PROFESSOR: The way Apple might
be with that is going to not
let anybody program it.
It's going to have a very
restrictive development
program internally so they can
basically say, I'm going to
take this person from this
person and put it together.
They will try to do everything
in one unified way.
So to some extent it might work,
but then you suddenly
realize Apple hired programmers
to keep up with
all the needs.
So it may even start to have
other people running things.
ARVIND: Internally their
software is--
AUDIENCE: So is there something
parallel going on in there?
ARVIND: Guaranteed there
will be parallel
stuff going on there.
Guaranteed because all the
communication stuff has to go
on in parallel with the
computation stuff.
So I mean, phones have to lots
of things in parallel if for
no other reason just
because of power.
It takes less power when you
do things in parallel as
opposed to when you do
sequentially because then you
have to run much
faster in that.
OK, so a method of designing
and connecting modules has
that functionality and
performance are predictable.
And must facilitate natural
description of concurrent
systems. A method of refining
individual modules into
hardware or software for
systems on a chip.
So refinement is a highly
technical word.
What that means is that you have
written a program and you
move on to rewrite it, but
nobody can tell from outside
that you rewrote it.
All right, so you refine
it and you can to
refine it into hardware.
I mean, you may implement it in
hardware in this as opposed
to transformation.
Transformation is automatic.
We're doing something, it's
guaranteed it's correct.
Refinement you may have to work
a little bit more to show
that it is correct
in some sense.
It's a correct refinement of
whatever you were doing.
So basically, just to get the
application going, which as
Allen is pointing out is the
major task and this is true
regardless of what people say.
When you get to complex system,
if people start
talking about performance
you're 90% there.
That means the damn
thing works.
So even the people may say, oh,
performance will be lousy.
Most of the energy is
just consumed in
getting it to work.
So never forget that.
So a refinement idea becomes
very important because you
want to take as many things as
possible, which are available.
Make it work and then
individually refine; modular
refinement of things.
AUDIENCE: Maybe just also
underscore, just to emphasis
what you're saying Arvind, our
salesmen will go and say
explicitly that they can
sell a factor of 2.
Just like you were saying.
Just a factor of 2 on 100
processors or whatever, they
can sell that if it works.
If it gives the right answer.
AUDIENCE: It's the ease.
ARVIND: The ease and confidence
that it's really
doing what you expect
it to do.
AUDIENCE: So it's really
performance second, ease of
use first. We've got it
backwards in academia.
ARVIND: But everybody set
designs on 2 multicores.
So why multicore problems
becomes hard and this where
hardware and software starts
diverging a little bit.
So what happens in
hardware design?
Everything is in parallel.
It's sitting right there,
this blog does this,
this blog does that.
So there's no confusion
in your mind
what's going on in parallel.
If you have to multiplex some
thing in hardware, that first
we'll do this then we'll do
that, that's also expressed
explicitly in the design.
Software is not like that.
You know, software have n
threads, but I have only 10 in
my hardware.
So there is another layer of
software or operating system
or whatever you want to call
it, runtime system.
Whose sole job is to virtualize
or to do time
multiplexing of underlying
resources and that makes the
problem harder.
You know, that makes the problem
harder whether you're
doing it in a way
that preserves
some performance goals.
Whether you're doing it so that
you want cause deadlocks,
so there are many, many issues
that come up in this.
And basically, when I said this
is an ideas kind of a
talk, I do know how to do this
and I still haven't worked
enough on this problem of
how to take this kind of
methodology where I can write
these parallel modules,
compose them.
How to map it onto multicores.
OK, so now let me tell
you something
technical about this stuff.
So this hardware inspired
methodology for synthesizing
parallel programs. Now I'm going
to use some fancy words.
So this is a rule-based
specifications or what I call
guarded atomic actions.
I will explain in a second
what that means.
It will let you think about
parallel systems in a very
different way.
So it's like saying look, if
this register is 2 and this
register is 3, you can add them
and put them here, 5.
And you can do this
any time you want.
So this is like a rule.
Invariant.
You're saying, I don't
care what's
happening in the machine.
This is always safe to do.
Now what I'm going to ask
you to do is take a huge
intellectual jump from this.
That if you give me enough
such rules you would have
completely described the
hardware, what it does.
Now why am I thinking
like this?
Because these invariants
are stated properly.
It's always possible to
understand the behavior of the
system as if one things at
a time is happening.
When 2 plus 3 is becoming 5, if
you want you can have this
mental picture-- the rest
of the world is frozen.
Nothing is changing
there, only that
change is taking place.
And you can think it terms of
these small, small changes and
all legal behaviors will be
explainable as some sequence
of these changes.
It's possible to describe
all kinds of hardware
using things like that.
Composition of modules with
guarded interfaces.
So this is the language called
Bluespec and it has a very
strong echoes of a language that
was designed in the 80s
by two guys, Chandry
and Misra, the
language called Unity.
But they never used it
for hardware design.
Their goals were different and
they didn't really have a
concept of a module
in that language.
So let me show you
3 examples here.
Greatest common divisor, just
to get off ground and then I
will show you 2 very different
problems: airlines reservation
query problem and the
video codec H.264.
We won't have time to get into
ordered list, but if somebody
wants to discuss that I've
be happy to show you.
OK, so now let's look at how do
I think of my design of my
program in Bluespec?
I always think in terms
of a bunch of modules.
And what's a module.
A module is going to have some
state elements in it.
If you're thinking software just
think each module guards
some variables, which nobody
else can touch.
You're the only one.
So you have a variable xyz, he
has some abcd, et cetera.
So each module has some.
That's what I'm showing
in red.
If you were thinking hardware,
think of thse things as
stateful elements like
registers or
flip flops of memories.
But the main point is if it is
here then it's not here.
You own something, this module
owns something, this module
owns something.
One.
Second thing is every module
has internal rules for
manipulating the state and the
rules are always going to be
of the form that if some
condition is true on this
you're allowed to make the
following changes to that.
So that's what the
rule looks like.
Some condition, if it holds
that by action I
mean, change the state.
Change the state of
those variables.
And it's all or nothing.
So if you have 2 variables and
if you want to change both of
them in a rule then the
execution of a rule means
either both of them will change
or neither will change.
There's nothing in between
you can see.
That's disallowed
by this model.
I mean, the reason
I have modules is
they're not totally disjoined.
You can actually access
the state.
Both read it and write it, but
you can't just arbitrarily
reach it and do something.
You have to go through some
interface methods the moment
you talk to some
other modules.
So this is the standard
information hiding principle.
You know, abstract data types,
whatever you want to call it.
You know, so there's an
interface through which you
will enter and if you're just
reading the values I think we
call them read methods or value
methods and if you're
going to effect the state of one
of the modules we'll call
those action methods.
Because you're actually
going to change the
state in some module.
So now, very strange execution
model here.
Very, very different from
sequential execution model.
So repeatedly you do
the following.
You pick a rule to execute.
Any rule, I don't care.
And select a rule to execute,
compute the state, what
updates should be made,
make the state update.
And then go and do it again,
so repeatedly you do this.
So this is a highly
nondeterministic thing,
selective rule.
There may be a gazillion
rules in your system.
So system privileges are
provided to control the
selection if you want.
But it's a detail that
we won't get into to.
So does everybody get the
model right here?
That you have a lot of
state elements and
you have lot of rules.
Many rules may be applicable,
pick one of them to execute.
Execute and that will
change the state.
Ask the same question again,
which rules are enabled?
No, pick any rule amongst
them and keep doing it.
Now semantics say one
rule at a time.
In any implementation we're
going to do many,
many rule in parallel.
But you don't have to
worry about that.
That will be done all
automatically.
That we can do many
rules in parallel.
OK, so now let's look at GCD.
So this is an ordinary
GCD program.
You can write it in any language
you want if y is zero
then x otherwise if this is
greater than GCD of y, x.
Otherwise you subtract.
So no problem and I'm sure
you know how it executes.
So if I was to take GCD of 6,15
you will see there is a
recursive call that'll go on
because 6 is less than 15 so
it will be this.
You get this and you get
this, et cetera.
Ultimately you get
3 as an answer.
Everybody is with me?
You know you all know GCD?
You can all write it in your
favorite language.
Now the question is, what does
it mean to execute this
program in a concurrent
setting?
We were not thinking parallel
or sequential, right?
This is GCD.
Someone who's teaching this
class says run it in parallel.
You say, what do you mean,
run it in parallel?
Oh, you mean that maybe I should
try to do several GCD
calls, recursive calls
in parallel?
That also doesn't make too
much sense in this.
Perhaps, this is what
someone meant.
You know that if he has some
program where there are 2
calls to GCD, he would like you
to do those 2 in parallel.
I mean, what does it mean
to do GCD in parallel?
Now let me contrast this with
how you would think about this
problem as a hardware person.
So your job is to build
a GCD machine.
You're going to make
millions of
dollars, GCD is very popular.
So you build this GCD machine.
You know, it has 2 inputs,
it has an output.
And this will be my module
I'm going to sell this
intellectual property
to everyone.
OK, so now let me talk of
parallel invocations of this.
You see in hardware there can
be no confusion, either you
have 2 GCD boxes or you
have 1 GCD box.
I mean, you can have as many
boxes as you want, but there
is no confusion about that.
You know how many GCDs you have.
So in some sense, if you
have many of them, you're
talking of independent calls.
Who knows what about
recursive calls?
I mean, that's internal story.
You know, that's a different
level of questions.
So this question will
automatically get asked.
In hardware you will ask the
question, does the answer come
out immediately?
Does it come out in
particular time?
Why's this question important?
Because if it's going to take
some time then while it's
computing the question I'm going
to ask is can I give
another set of inputs?
Are you with me?
I mean, that's a legitimate
question to ask.
If it's going to take half an
hour to compute the GCD can I
give it another input
while it's thinking?
Can the machine be shared
by 2 different users?
Can it be pipelined?
So you agree that all these
questions are meaningful in
hardware setting?
And I claim all these questions
are also meaningful
in software setting.
We just don't think like that.
This is exactly the problem we
are having right now when we
say that we have optimized
something
and we call it again.
We think off it as starting
a fresh, maybe not.
Maybe not.
You know, maybe we
should think of
it in terms of resources.
And the point I want to make
is I want to think of GCD
module as a resource.
Even in software I want to think
of it as a resource.
So that there is no ambiguity in
your mind whether you have
1 GCD or you have 2 GCDs.
If you're going to multiplex it
we'll write it differently.
If you're going to have 2
independent ones, which can go
on in parallel we'll write
it differently.
OK, so that's the idea I want
to borrow from the hardware
side of this.
So how would you do-- yes?
AUDIENCE: But how would you
decide how many GCDs to
instantiate?
Would that be is this model
left up to the programmer?
ARVIND: Well, you see that's
the big difference between
hardware and software.
That in hardware you have no
design until you have taken
that decision.
AUDIENCE: Right.
I mean, hardware designs once
it's built, it's built.
Software designs you want the
same module of software to
seamlessly run on different
kinds of hardware.
ARVIND: That doesn't mean that
I can't recompile it or can't
resynthesize it or something.
So it may be same source
description in software.
AUDIENCE: Right, if your source
subscription specifies
2 GCD modules and you have 8
cores, you're not necessarily
going to take very
good advantage of
this, so how do you--
ARVIND: No, no.
The way I would like to think
about that is that it'll be
highly parameterized code and
you will plug in some
information like that
and resynthesize
the parallel program.
AUDIENCE: So the software or
some sort of macro meta
software has to determine the
extent to which the problem
should be distributed.
ARVIND: Well, you can think
like that, but really this
integration will be much
tighter than you think.
So for example, let me just
give you some more insight
from the hardware side.
So in the hardware side it's
standard practice that will
have some RTL code, I'll
have some code.
And I plug in the library.
What kind of gates have I got?
Have I got 2 input gates,
4 input gates, whatever.
There will be a huge library.
The same code can be compiled
using different libraries.
So you choose something
at synthesis time.
Another thing that'll happen in
hardware is what is called
generic statements.
So you may have a loop
which assigns a
register file with n registers.
Which will conceptually makes
sense, it will make sense in
simulation, but when it comes
to synthesizing it you
have to specify n.
So I'm going towards that
kind of methodology.
That you will have highly
parameterized code, but many
parameters you have to specify
before you will say, now my
program is ready to run on
this parallel machine.
And this is totally
unexplored.
As I said, this is an idea
level them being.
AUDIENCE: So this adds a
problem that is not in
traditional hardware
synthesis, mainly
picking all the n's.
Ideally you wouldn't want to
have to have the programmer to
come up with creative algorithms
because they're
going to have lots
and lots of .
ARVIND: Absolutely.
We may have lots of defaults.
We may other level of smart
programs, which look at this
and they instantly go and
set many parameters.
You know, so there will
be a practical side,
many issues like that.
But main point I'm trying to
make is that I really want to
synthesize.
I want to instantiate a program,
synthesize a program
for a given configuration
of hardware.
Let's look at the
GCD in Bluespec.
If I'm going to find the GCD
of 2 numbers I need 2
registers, x and y; so
that's what this is.
Make me a register.
If you want, make
me 2 variables.
You know, make me variable
x and y,
initial values are zero.
So this is what is called
the state of the module.
It knows about and x
and y, nobody else
knows about x and y.
What are the dynamics of it?
How do I compute this?
So internal behavior is being
described and this is exactly
what you saw earlier in saying
that there is a swap rule.
If x is greater than y and y is
not equal to zero then you
swap x and y, so this is a
parallel composition. x gets
y, y gets x.
In this system all the reads
take place instantaneously and
then you do all the writes
at the end of it.
Don't read this sequentially,
you read x and y in parallel
and then you go and
update x and y.
Does this rule make sense?
I mean, if you know
anything GCD--
if x is greater than y than
you're going to swap it and
subtraction, if x is less than
or equal to y than y
gets y minus x.
So this is very interesting.
Now you have 2 registers x and
y and I've given 2 rules and
I'm saying you can apply these
rules anytime you want.
Just repeatedly keep
doing these rules.
Now what does the outside
world know about this?
What do you want to advertise
about GCD
to the outside world?
You don't want to give
away your secret.
This is your intellectual
property of how you're
computing the GCD.
You just want to be use GCD.
So the outside world can say,
oh find me start it.
With a and b. x gets
a, y gets b.
It's going to give you 2
parameters, but we may be busy
computing so we have a guard
here which says, if y is
zero-- this is internal,
outside
world doesn't see this.
If y is zero then only then can
you start it, otherwise
you can't start it.
Otherwise it means it's
busy computing.
OK, similarly when is the
result available?
When the y is zero then you
have the result and
you will return x.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
ARVIND: That's right.
So that'll be more
sophisticated.
And that's exactly the kind
of decision I do want the
designers to take because you
may want to put a five hole.
You may just keep spitting
out results.
You can make it as sophisticated
as you want.
Tag it if you want.
No predetermined thing.
So first question I ask you,
what happened to those
recursive calls?
You know, if you go back to the
previous slide there was a
recursively called GCD, which
you were all comfortable with.
There is no GCD call here.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
ARVIND: Right, so there's
a notion of a
cycle event or something.
Look at it now, update
it, look at it again.
You know, so there's like an
infinite loop here, which is
always going.
Which is exactly how
hardware works.
It doesn't have to be
synchronous, but if you want
to have a simple model
in your head just
think, there's the clock.
You know, look at this state,
pick one route to execute,
update it, then it's the
next clock cycle.
Keep doing this repeatedly.
It's details here, but I can
take such a description and
actually produce that machine
for you, which does the GCD.
What I'm much more interested
in is, this is how I want to
think about my GCD now.
So I've hidden everything
inside it.
And it has 2 methods: start and
result and there is a very
strong notion of when
a method is ready--
because it may be busy
computing, it doesn't want to
listen to you.
So there is this notion of
something being ready and if
it's an action method then
you're only allowed to enable
it when it's ready.
So this is a high-level
protocol that
compiler will enforce.
It'll never ever set this,
it'll never execute this
unless it is ready
to be executed.
And of course, when you're going
to enable it then you
have to give me 2 arguments
that go with it.
And what does this
really mean?
The result is valid.
So if are to do types et cetera,
this would easily be
baby type or something.
Tag union type that validates
is being coded here.
So really to the world
you are just
advertising this interface.
There is a GCD interface
and it has 2 methods.
An action method, which is
called start and a result
method, which is just a
value kind of a thing.
And in order to do this
you have to give me an
int a into b in this.
An end of interface.
Now this is borrowing a lot
from modern programming
languages so for example,
I can easily make it
polymorphic.
It doesn't have to
be ints here.
You know, what is the
meaning of int?
You can specify the
type in this.
So it'll be a's of type t,
b's of type t et cetera.
What are the examples
of type t here?
It could be a 32 bit integer, it
could be 16 bit integer, it
could be 17 bit integer,
whatever you want and whatever
makes sense.
So this is the kind of thing
that you always take care of
when you synthesize things.
It won't synthesize until you
specify the type, but the
description remains the same.
And you will instantiate
it for a given type.
This I'm showing you
for one reason.
If you are coming from the
hardware side really these
ideas and types and sensations
are very sophisticated.
I mean, this is getting
as advanced as
you can have in software.
The other very interesting
thing is, and this is the
abstract data type kind of
thinking, you can go and
completely change the
implementation of this.
If you have a clever algorithm
for doing GCD, fine, go
ahead and do it.
You know, it doesn't effect
the users of this.
So this is a very important
property for composition.
All I insist on is that every
method has this ready thing
coming on so that I don't make
mistakes in wiring it.
I will involve this method
only when it's ready.
So in some sense if you forget
about the ready thing, I'm
just borrowing ideas from object
oriented languages.
You know, you have a class, you
have methods on it, and
all I'm saying is oh, you should
manipulate this state
in a very systematic manner
using these methods.
But then I'm injecting some
hardware idea here, which
doesn't exist in
software today.
That is, oh, a method
may not be ready.
And even that can be captured
very abstractly and done
properly in this.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: So then in the case
of making models I was
thinking of spy nature.
So if you want to basically
synthesize the hardware you
may also better efficiency by
having set of synchronized
protocol by taking the
output [OBSCURED]
number of cycles.
ARVIND: I think, yes.
That'll be a low-level detail
that if it is synchronized
then you will actually try to
manipulate it like that.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
ARVIND: OK, right.
So let me just quickly say
what the languages is.
So you have modules, then you
have state variables, and you
have rules and you have action
methods and read methods.
What I wanted to show
you is what is
the language of actions.
So when I write an action here
or an action here, what is it?
So simplest action is assignment
to a variable,
assigment to a register.
This is a conditional action,
so if predicate is true then
do this action, otherwise no
action, no change in state.
This is a parallel
composition.
Do a1 and a2 in parallel.
Sequential composition, the
effects of this are visible to
this, et cetera.
This is a call to a method
of one of the module.
And then there is a guard.
And you have an expression
language, which is there's
nothing special here.
So this is just simply you
can read a variable,
you can have constants.
These are just names
and there's nothing
special going on here.
Let me explain you guards.
So people find guards versus
if's confusing.
And this is one way
to understand it.
So guards affect the
surroundings.
If I wrote here a1 when p1 in
parallel with a2 think of
guard as something to
do with resources.
I really don't want you to
do a1 unless p1 is true.
p1 made a fact that the
module was busy.
Some predicate here.
But I want the effect of this
whole thing to be atomic.
So if any part of it can't be
done then the whole thing
can't be done.
And therefore the affect of
guard is as if you wrote a1 in
parallel with a2 when p1.
In other words, guard on
anything becomes guard on
everything in that parallel
composition.
Do you understand what
I just said?
This is very important for
composition of guards.
Because I want the
atomicity of the
whole thing to be preserved.
So if anything can't be done
that means the whole thing
can't be done.
On the other hand, conditional
action is
just conditional action.
So if I have if p1 than a1 in
parallel with a2, well that's
like saying if p1 was true then
I want to do a1 and a2 in
parallel, otherwise I
just want to do a2.
So there is a very big
difference between conditional
actions and guards.
Guards are something
about resources.
I need it for proper composition
of atomic actions.
AUDIENCE: I have question.
So are they entirely
equal into.
Because this is maybe a
low-level question, but in the
first case-- so the first
case in the left.
Can't you start doing a2
and then roll it back
or something [OBSCURED]
ARVIND: Oh, I think there may be
many tricks you can play in
implentation.
You can be optimistic,
you can--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ARVIND: No.
No.
Semantically this is this
defining the semantics.
I mean, this is the algebra.
This has to be true because
I'm saying this is
what a guard is.
AUDIENCE: Right, so the
semantically equal but not
[OBSCURED].
ARVIND: Well I mean, that's
probably not the
right way to say it.
I mean, semantics are
being defined.
You have choice in
implementations.
I mean I'm not telling you
how to implement this.
Let me go on with this.
So here is a problem that was
posed to me by Jayadev Misra.
This is quasi realistic
problem.
Ask for codes from 2 airlines.
If one code is below $300,
buy immediately.
$300 is sort of the cheapest
ticket you get these dates.
Buy the lower quote
if over $300.
But as some-- say your patience
runs out, say I can't
wait anymore.
So after one minute buy from
whosoever has quoted otherwise
flag error.
Is this a realistic scenario?
You can express it
using threads.
And you can write a scheduler
to do this, et cetera.
Those things are not as succint
as you would like.
I mean, you'd be surprised, in
this simple a problem how
complicated and how many
questions will arise if you
express this as a threaded
computation.
Now let me show you
what you will do--
in Bluuspec.
OK, so we are going to make
a module, which does what?
Make get quotes.
This module's job is
to get quotes.
So what kind of state elements
do you expect it to have?
Well airline a may be quoting
some value, airline b may be
quoting some value.
Whether we are done or not
there's a timer, which we're
going to be bumping,
et cetera.
And they'll be rules you know,
get a quote from a, which will
be when not done do something.
Executes when a responds.
Get b, timeout, et cetera.
There are there ruls
of this sort.
Let me just show you
one methodd.
So method, this is how
you will start it--
you have this module get quotes
and you're saying book
me a ticket and this
is your request r.
Now obviously this can
only be done when the
module is not busy.
If module is busy the
you can't do it.
So what will you do when
you get such a request?
Tell me this makes sense.
So what is this saying?
Try to get a request
from a in parallel.
Try to get a request from b.
Now you are busy.
The module is busy so done
equals false here.
And I'm initializing this.
I'm just saying that a quote
right now is infinity and b
quote is infinity and
timer is zero.
Fair?
And when will I get ticket?
Well, when done then you'll
return the ticket from this.
Now let's look at example
of a rule.
So you may have a rule like
this, pick cheapest. You see
the interesting thing in this is
you'll be able to read this
independently of what else is
going on in this system.
And let's see, what does
this rule say?
Is it succint?
Rules says when you are not done
and if the quote from a
is not infinite that
means a has quoted.
And b has also quoted, then
what should happen?
If a is less than b then
buy the ticket from a.
Otherwise you'll buy the ticket
from b and you're done.
I'm not going to write all these
rules, but I think you
should be able to--
I'm certain you can
write these rules.
What's happening here that is
just separation of concerns.
It's all concurrenct stuff.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
ARVIND: Parallel?
AUDIENCE: Or like, for
lack of better words
the type in the name.
ARVIND: Sorry, say it again.
AUDIENCE: So as the ampersand,
how does that
interact with the--
PROFESSOR: Can you hold that
question first because we will
run out of space.
AUDIENCE: So the ampersand after
not done that is, what
sort of ordering is that?
ARVIND: It's just, I mean,
associative, commutative.
Kind of thing.
It's all happening
in parallel.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED].
ARVIND: This thing, right?
I mean, think of it like this,
these are variables and you're
checking their values
right now.
So it's just a combination
kind of a query
that you have here.
AUDIENCE: So I guess you're
checking there's
new activity happening.
ARVIND: That's right.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't matter
which order you check.
AUDIENCE: So I guess what I'm
trying to get is that the
whole block at the top is
executed in parallel with the
block at the bottom?
ARVIND: No.
Those things are not
in parallel.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
ARVIND: Now I just want to show
you this because it's
completely different from
airline reservations.
You know, H.264 this is a
codec that is being used
everywhere and we'll
be used even more.
And this is a typical data flow
diagram you will find for
this kind of thing.
You don't have to understand
anything about this except
that conceptually you just
have five flows for
communicating between them and
in all such things the goal is
that it has to be able to
sustain a certain amount of
rate at which dat is to be
processed and it's usually
forgiving in terms
of latencies.
So if latency increases a little
bit here and there it's
usually OK-- when things
go in and come out.
A data flow like network.
And another reason why this
example is fascinating is
because it's done regularly both
in hardware and software
and any mixture of the two.
So for example, when it runs
on your PC it's being done
100% in software and I think
on iPods there are special
purpose hardware for doing it
and therefore the battery can
last much longer.
And on cell phones it's kind of
in between in this and it's
a question of what frame rate
you want to process?
If you're procssing very high
frame rate then it'll have to
be done in hardware.
So when we got into this thing
we said, OK, we wanted to
build hardware for doing this.
And reference codes that are
available, it's 80,000 lines
and it sort of gives
you a heart attack.
You know, you read this
and you say, whoa!
And it doesn't need
the performance.
I mean, that reference code, if
it ran on your laptop you
won't be able to watch
a movie with this.
And there is the Linux version
of it, which gives you even a
bigger heart attack because
it's 200,000 lies and many
different codecs are
mixed in this.
The biggest problem here it is
none of these codes reflect
that picture I showed you
of the previous diagram.
Because the way people approach
it in software is
they take some input from
here and they push it
as far as they can.
And that's it.
Then they will take the next
input and push it.
So different boxes keep
modifying it as they see fit
and as a reader you can't tell,
oh, this is this part
and this is this part.
I mean, there are no 54Q's.
Why?
Because 54Q's are expensive
in software.
You know, it will
involve copying.
You know, you'll write it here
then you'll read it again,
which is a bad idea
in software.
So in some sense, the software
will thinking already entered.
In this style of coding there
is no model of concurrency.
So it's not clear to me when
you give me that quote what
all I can do in parallel in
order to preserve the
semantics of this.
I mean the problem is much,
much harder here.
So you will just do some
high-level analysis of the
code, but you have lost a lot
of information that was all
present in the source--
could've been present
in the source.
And my claim is it can
be done differently.
So this has been done by
Chun-Chieh and this I'm
showing you a month old slide,
but he has done a lot more
work since then and the total
code in Bluespec is 9000 lines
for this contrasting it with
80,000 versus 200,000 kind of
stuff and this is telling you
the amount of code in various
blocks in this.
And since it's done in Bluespec
you can take it and
you can go and implement it all
in hardware, so you can
synthesize it.
It actually does now 45 frames
per second, actually 90 frames
even per second today.
You know, so this
is a month old.
This is the main point.
Once you have done this
now you can refine it.
You have a different
preference.
You say, oh, I want to
do this differently.
So you can go and rewrite
any module again.
It will be very, very easy
to do this in the system.
It is very difficult to do this
in the reference code, so
that's one point to be made.
The second thing is you
don't have to do
everything in hardware.
If you wanted you could have
implemented any part of it in
software, so you can take the
same kind of a description and
generate software
from it as well.
So each module can be
refined separately.
Behaviors of modules
are composable.
You know, you can take these
things and it's predictable
what will happen when you
compose these things in terms
of performance and in terms of
resources also, it's very
clear what's happening.
In hardware the resources
will be area and time
and so on in this.
So takeaway.
Parallel programming should be
based on well-defined modules
and parallel composition
of such modules.
Modules must embody a notion of
resources and consequently,
sharing in time multiplex use.
This is a controversial point.
And guard atomic actions and
modules with guarded
interfaces provide a solid
foundation for doing so.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Now we ran a little bit late,
so if you have questions you
can ask about programs.